die hansestadt stendal in sachsen anhalt
hat sich im innenhof des historischen
rathauses diesen aufzug einbauen lassen
für 184 1000 euro ein echtes schnäppchen
dachte man aber das ding ist langsam
sehr langsam und es gibt noch ein
weiteres ganz entscheidendes problem
aus sicherheitsgründen darf der aufzug
nicht alleine genutzt werden jede fahrt
muss ein eigens geschulter mitarbeiter
der stadt durchführen absolut irre
finden dass viele bürger 20 minuten
haben wir da ist ein bisher niemand kam
und ja uns die aufzug bediente und ja 20
minuten verschenkt oder dieser aufzucht
oder ein schildbürgerstreich der
stadtplanung wenn da mal jemand von der
verwaltung noch dabei stehen muss das ja
auch blöd ich denke das ist quatsch
damit alle stockwerke barrierefrei
erreicht werden baut die stadt stendal
den aufzug um geld zu sparen entscheidet
man sich im rathaus für diese billig
version
dabei gibt es keine geschlossene
fahrstuhl kabine sondern ihr wird eine
offene plattform nach oben gezogen
tja und zwischen plattformen
aufzugsschacht passen schon mal ein paar
finger verletzungsgefahr
deshalb muss in stendal bei jeder fahrt
ein behördlicher liftboy entsprechend
der betriebserlaubnis darf dieser
fahrstühlen nur in begleitung von
geschulten personen genutzt werden
dazu sind im rathaus sieben mitarbeiter
geschult die mitarbeiter müssen während
der gesamten fahrt den finger auf der
taste lassen denn nur so geht's voran
mit sage und schreibe 15 zentimetern pro
sekunde
der zuständige bauamtsleiter kann die
öffentliche aufregung über den schnecken
aufzug nicht verstehen wir leben heute
in einer hektischen zeit den gegner und
die bürger wollen alles schnell
erledigen und dann ist natürlich dass
nach oben und unten fahren wofür man
vielleicht eineinhalb minuten braucht
wird schon als zu lang empfunden kann
ich auch nicht ganz nachvollziehen
andere in der stendaler stadtverwaltung
wohl doch denn man hat im rathaus jetzt
noch mal 20.000 euro in die hand
genommen um zu prüfen ob aus dem ding
ein ganz gewöhnlicher aufzug gemacht
werden
kann man gleich anders planen sollen
dass man gleich verbessere gemacht
billig gekauft das doppelt gekauft und
das gilt für privaten genauso viel für
die öffentliche hand soll die ersparnis
ist ja nicht da was sie damit erreichen
wollten beziehungsweise wir zahlen jetzt
noch drauf nicht auszuschließen dass der
aufzug doch noch komplett ausgetauscht
wird das würde dann noch mal 200.000
euro kosten dann würde der fahrstuhl
wohl endgültig das teuerste schnäppchen
der hansestadt